in 2014 I announced one of my boldest
companies it's a company called human
longevity Inc co-founded it with craig
Venter the first guy to sequence the
human genome and Bob harary when the top
stem cell scientists and businessman in
the world and we founded human longevity
incorporated as a means to extend the
healthy human lifespan to make a hundred
years old than you 60 and in the first
year of operations we built the largest
genome sequencing facility in the world
and that genome sequencing facility
besides your genome the 3.2 billion
letters from your father and the 3.2
billion letters from your mother we are
also sequencing your microbiome you are
a collection of 10 trillion human cells
and 100 trillion bacterial cells but
besides that your full phenotype your
your MRI the full imaging of your body
your metabolomic 24 chemicals in your
bloodstream all of this data is being
collected and then we're using machine
learning to mine that data for the
secrets of what drives cancer what
drives heart disease what drives
neurodegenerative disease with a mission
of making sure that when you're a
hundred you look good you move good you
think good you feel great and I think
that's where we're going our ability to
rapidly sequence a genome take what was
a hundred million dollars and nine
months down to a thousand bucks in a few
hours is going to unlock the secrets we
are the product of our genome how you
look how you sound the structures of
your brain are all coded for in our
genes so as we unlock this we're going
to create tremendous breakthroughs in
the healthy human lifespan inventing new
drugs that are personalized to you it's
going to reinvent health on an epic
scale
you